kirsten dunst sheds tears at the 70th  annual can Film Festival but what made  her cry  [Music]  star stepped out on the red carpet in  Cannes France turning heads and studying  gowns and tuxedos for this year's  black-tie event and yeah of course yeah  the best Kirsten looked like a princess  in a blue ball gown with a plunging  neckline as she and her beagle cast  mates had their big moment at their  film's premiere Wednesday but photos  emerged of Kirsten wiping away tears  after suddenly breaking down the actress  has yet to address her outbursts but  we're hoping those were tears of joy  after her fairytale entrance back in  March Kirsten told ET all about the  beguiled the movie hits theaters June  2nd it's um a Southern gothic kind of  bodice Ripper movie it's a remake of  Eastwick it is a yes it was a remake but  it's done now from kind of the female  perspective  [Music]